not every actor who is forced to play a
role they hate regret it such is the
case with Robert Patterson whose part as
Edward Cullen in the Twilight films made
him an interational Superstar and
allowed him to be able to pick more
personal Indie projects like High Life
Cosmopolis and the lighthouse that
earned him critical Acclaim nevertheless
playing the sparkly vampire Edward
wasn't a good experience for him in the
first Twilight as the actor said he
hated his character and felt he was at
risk of being fired every day and it was
a role he was forced to continue playing
for three more movies over the years is
pson has been candid about his dislike
for the Twilight series as well as his
critique of its author Stephanie Meyer
after reading the books he told e some
things about Edward is so specific I was
just convinced like this woman is mad
she's completely mad and she's in love
with her own fictional creation and
sometimes you would feel uncomfortable
reading this thing if it hadn't been so
successful I think people would have
thought it was really weird it's a
really weird story